auch von so was ähnliches wie
schulalltag sind wir in deutschland
natürlich noch meilenweit entfernt
sie haben eine klassische potter filme
werden heute gar nicht mehr möglich
unter den umständen sicher ist nur kein
regulärer unterricht mehr bis zum herbst
ansonsten heißt es einzelne jahrgänge
sollen in kleinen gruppen oder tage
beziehungsweise wochenweise in die
schule
der rest lernt irgendwie digital mit der
betonung auf irgendwie digitale tafeln
computer laptops diese hamburger
grundschule ist verhältnismäßig gut
ausgestattet was fehlt sind lehrer die
sich mit der technik auskennen
da kauft so ein teures whiteboard und
dann sagt der alte dateien lehrer wächst
dann bleibt ja gar nicht dran hängen
nach einer umfrage der robert bosch
stiftung sind zwei drittel der deutschen
schulen nicht gut auf digitalen
fernunterricht vorbereitet es gibt total
engagierte lehrer die unterrichten in
videokonferenzen
andere schicken per whatsapp aufgaben
und stellen sich danach wochenlang tot
und alle pädagogen fühlen sich zu recht
von der politik alleingelassen
bei der lehrergewerkschaft gew in köln
gehen seit tagen hilferufe von pädagogen
ein die das chaos rund um die schule
öffnung beschreiben hier zb schreibt
eine dass ihre schülerinnen und schüler
dazu angehalten werden
seife und papierhandtücher selbst
mitzubringen wir diese volk nicht
vorhanden sind natürlich nicht schön wir
auch wenn jeder noch ein paar glühbirnen
mitbringen könnte und einen verwandten
der sich mit ipads aus kennt ja dass die
realität man möchte im moment wirklich
keinen lehrer sein
carolin kebekus zum beispiel leitet die
carmen nebel gesamtschule in frechen und
wendet sich mit einer geradezu
verzweifelten videobotschaft an die
eltern läuft das mit den jetzt oder was
sie jetzt auf rekord drücken auf den
tracks gerät trotzdem strahlt liebe
eltern wie ich der presse entnehmen
musste findet bei uns ab nächste woche
für manche jahrgänge wie der unterricht
statt und natürlich verstehe ich gut
dass viele von ihnen nun sagen unsere
kinder waren fünf wochen am stück zu
hause wir können die schlicht nicht mehr
sehen
glauben sie mir nach fünf wochen mit
ihren
dann geht es mir immer genauso wie viele
von ihnen haben jetzt fragen ich aber
auch was mache ich zum beispiel den rest
des jahres mit meinem sportlehrer keine
ahnung ich hasse den schon zweimal am
tag mein auto waschen damit er irgendwas
zu tun hat und weil ich einfach zu gerne
sehe wie dieser man sich bückt dafür
fallen lehrer aus die ich dringend
brauche
weil sie über 60 sind oder schwanger wir
werden ja ständig kolleginnen schwanger
dabei ruhig schon jeden morgen im
lehrerzimmer heimlich eine ganze packung
anti baby pillen in den kaffee jahr lang
hat es doch keine sau gejuckt das
deutsche schule in kaum waschbecken
haben und kein warmes wasser
jetzt sollen wir ihn nur 14 tagen ein
hygiene konzept erarbeiten das problem
ist doch nicht fehlende seife unsere
toiletten sind so ekelhaft
an unserer schule geht man gar nicht
aufs klo der letzte schüler der hier
aufs klo gegangen ist war der kleine tim
das war 2006
man hat nie wieder etwas von ihm gehört
bei uns läuft digitales lernen meistens
so der lehrer fotografiert eine seite im
schulbuch dann weiß er nicht wie er das
bild als anhang einer mail verschicken
kann also schickt er das ganze handy per
post an seinen 12 jährigen neffen wer
das dann für ihn machen muss sollte was
das schulsystem in jahren verpennt hat
können wir nicht in tagen nachholen
und wenn sie deswegen sauer sind
schreiben sie gefälligst an army merkel
oder angela lasse keine ahnung aber
lassen sie mich dann hole ich habe weist
dort genug damit zu tun mir zu überlegen
sich jetzt mit leeren mehr unterricht
machen und wer sagt denn jetzt erscheint
mit dieser kamera
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]